where do you think guys would find a
good woman yeah in your opinion and what
kind of woman do you like physically
forget the mentals because we're guys
and we look at them for their physical
first yeah yeah we do yeah
Instagram
Instagram yeah you know what combo
for me live your truth bro live
because you see it yeah like you get a
snapshot you can look at the highlights
you can see what they look like from
videos and you can kind of make in a way
you can make a visual Assumption of if
they take the boxes
yeah
trust me it is I've been catfished
plenty of times
but but I've learned from my mistakes
what to look out for you know I mean
where do you get catfish when you get
catfish yeah in your head it goes
[Laughter]
[Music]
I think that's number one come on hey
that's that's very reasonable I think
that's yes you could end the show there
all right what do you think about it
Mike so
yeah I was actually talking to Adam
about this I I use LinkedIn and so oh
like uh I mean that that's critical
right like I think even
um you know you you go like and they
love that right because the certain
girls they they want that their
protection is whoa this guy you know he
was at the yard party at Harvard
Business School right everybody like
listen all my people we we drive forms
we drive Teslas like we're we got money
I mean look like look at my LinkedIn you
know so that's number one
and then your linkedin's the flex store
in your circles right right you know so
again you couldn't a lot of the guys in
the library like let's say Obama right
or even like the guys that are you know
like Italian cars fast cars they're in
the library but then they're buying they
own the club afterwards right but anyway
like my type
she literally has to be
between I don't like five foot five foot
one but between five foot two and five
foot let's say three
yeah that's specific because look the
physical attraction is important so you
have to be fit like I like curvy girls
too but in terms of like the lady I want
she has to be fit she has to be in the
gym she needs to have like breasts and
butt like she needs to be curvy and then
women like you need to provide the
timber you like but if she's smaller
then
then like when we if we do do the do and
afterwards she's like I feel vulnerable
I want to cuddle she wants to cuddle
with somebody that is bigger bigger than
her so I I agree you couldn't have no
argument yeah that's why I say I I say
this advice to guys yeah I didn't mean
to call you
like bro at the end of the day a lot of
times yeah guys will say oh yeah girls
are saying that I need a guy bigger than
me or whoever you are bro go for a girl
go for girls are smaller than you bro
like don't bruh it's just that's just
the way it is bruh like that's just the
way it is anyway can I ask you a
question
where do we find the good responsibility
I don't know I don't know where's your
people now I don't know where do I find
more like you you can't oh I'm just a
hologram find your pearls he's blushing
he's actually blushing right now
remember when I said to him he would be
smiling on the shirt and he said I'll
never smile now look at him look at his
cheeky oh baby
I was having a good time look he's
smiling again
so I'm wincing it's different it's pain
oh anyway he didn't respond it's your
turn no I'm the host I don't have to
answer questions
where do you find good women and what's
your type good women um in the on planet
Earth that's where you find them
planet Earth
they need to know you're here coaching
exactly come on be responsible okay now
play like this yeah
dating apps is crap yeah that's the
bottom of the barrel yeah you might get
some easy beats though still get me I'll
go get a hinge has been good to me get
POF when I was in America that was good
to me still get me but really truly the
best place or the best way to find girls
or girlfriend is through your Social
Circle really and truly because then you
can get the CV you can get the resume
you can get the work history you can get
the references bro because when when
you're out in the world and you're just
dating randoms yeah like oh nothing says
I'll I'll keep it real my last
ex-girlfriend the white and Asian thing
yeah I met her at a train station and
just randomly at a train station I saw
her as she got off the train I was like
right she's buff I'm leaving to her like
because I don't wait in it I'm just like
like you got I'm saying shock don't stop
moving anyway so boom now
um that was that but at the same time
that's risky when you do them kind of
things because if you don't know nothing
about her there's no connections but if
she could be the top headers in the ends
bro you know what I'm saying she could
be a badass bro like she could be doing
corn doing all kinds of things in her
spare time just for fun not even for
Peas Just For Fun and then now you're
wiping up he's taking it to the extent
just a past time bro just a past time
hobbies yummy just heading man's but
anyway I'm so good you are so vulgar
it's mad so it's really dangerous when
you don't have no kind of connection to
this girl like and another thing is
another one is that's a danger like if
the girls moved away from where she grew
up so now you've met her in the
different ends no one knows her so now
it's like oh I got me a good one I got
brother you don't know what the dirt she
was doing back in the ends what she left
[Laughter]
you get me get me so yeah but I think
really the social group is the best like
I think the best experiences I've had
with girls has been like when I've met
them through somebody that I trust and
then they've been like nah she's a
decent she's all right bro like like
she's calming it and then like yeah cool
then that's it and then you know
okay what's the time now what's my type
good looking
there you go do you don't have specifics
he's just trying to be difficult look at
this what is this he wants to play on
the mysterious dangerous bad boy okay
cool that's what you look like though
I'm playing the game come on look at his
face anyway back to the Super Chat
um what is it
um where we at
where we at though
breathing heavy in that all right
um uh pick up recall you you ever notice
men don't normally choose a woman who
who's breaking the law why is that men
choose logically plan plain and simple
[Laughter]
even commit they can commit crimes
stealing from hair shops and [ __ ] oh
that's dead why would you even wifey
because I wouldn't wipe your criminal
that's in that episode ratchet ratchet
some ratchet girls are hot you know
don't bruh some girls in the hood are
hot bro like you get me they're just
ratchet and rather they'll just bring
drama and confusion to your life but
anyway what was I gonna ask I was gonna
ask the guy something would they let go
yeah would you date a girl with a fill
it uh was it a convict she's an
ex-convict it's just no upset huh
there's just no upside it's just this is
what's the point that's what I'm saying
what is the point I I get it where women
do it because obviously they love money
what so so so the criminals that they
want they're getting the fast money so
that's what attracts them in the first
place like girls don't want broke
criminals if you're if you're a criminal
and you're still stressed out and
struggling and you can't even afford
chicken and chips to take your girl like
the girls don't want that they weren't
in the criminals are making money
because the girls love money okay what
do you think about anything for a man
you're the provider so you don't really
need to go for a girl that's
doing done yeah I think I think you I
think guys I think guys know that like
if she's doing Badness she's a headache
but you know what I'm saying I don't
want that bro like what do you think bro
I mean I I can kind of see it because
you know like not to get into any
personal experiences but let's I mean it
could be fun and it could be exciting if
you're not trying to commit to someone
and they're like you know they're
they're like doing drug you know like
drugs and LSD showrooms like all that
kind of stuff and they're kind of like
go down the line the periodic table of
elements bro but yeah I mean it could be
fun and exciting right and so I mean I
could but you're not gonna wipe them up
right you know because you don't want
drama you don't want to get me too
especially that and like you can't
afford that so you know you make it you
have your fun you do your thing and then
you do move on all right everybody
watching make sure you subscribe to the
channel yeah this is the realest on yeah
bro this is just as real as it gets bruh
I don't see no other YouTubers doing
this kind of content rather on this kind
of vulgar level
but still keeping it classy at the same
time you see the balance because I'm a
Libra you're in the balance family yeah
kill me get me see I say some raw stuff
the girls may not like me but they still
love me as many of you
many of you just bear
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible